[Music]
hi
my name is nicole kramer and i'm a third
year bioinformatics and computational
biology graduate student
at the university of north carolina at
chapel hill today i'm really honored to
be talking to you
about a new paradigm for multi-figure
coordinate based plotting in r
that i've begun to make possible with my
package bento box
the inspiration for this package and
this functionality within the r plotting
environment
came from some of my own stressful
experiences as a grad
student making figures and plots there
was one time when my advisor
asked me to make a multi-paneled figure
that looked something like this
there were two heat map style plots in a
specific genomic region
there were two tracks of jeans below
that
there were six different tracks of bin
signal data below those
and there was a bar graph of some
statistical analyses done in r
and since i work in genomics all of this
data
was huge one heat map came from a file
that was 55 gigabytes
and the other came from a file that was
14 gigabytes
one set of those bin data came from
three different files that totaled 1.2
gigabytes
and the other came from three other
files that totaled 1.7 gigabytes
and on top of this data being huge the
process to make this combined figure was
extremely tedious and time consuming
with all of its elements coming from
different places
there were different screenshots of a
couple of genomic browsers
there was a plot made from data analyzed
in r
everything was cropped and arranged in
adobe illustrator
and all of the fine-tuning and nice
labels were also made
in adobe illustrator
so when my advisor asked me to change
the genomic coordinates i was looking at
in this figure
it wasn't a simple fix and i went to my
overcrowded laptop screen
with a bunch of genomic browsers open
with my dropbox open with all the files
i was working with
my rstudio window my adobe illustrator
window
and the paper i was taking inspiration
from and
i became completely overwhelmed
i thought that there had to be an easier
way
to make figures like this beyond
existing browsers
beyond existing programmatic libraries
and things that i didn't need to use
graphic design software for
that would let me make and arrange all
my plots in one place
something that was entirely reproducible
by being completely programmatic
yet entirely customizable and
efficient for handling large data
specifically
and so my team and i developed a package
called bentobox
that allows for coordinate based
plotting in r where plots can be
programmatically made
and arranged on a user-defined page
layout with common units of measurement
here is an example i'm showing you two
tiny page markings with
inches and centimeters
so let's talk about how bento box makes
figures entirely programmatic
if we go back to that figure i made by
combining screenshots in adobe
illustrator
i can now make a precisely tailored
version of that figure
entirely in r the code on the left is
every command needed to make the figure
on the right
i've squished it down for you here and
it's not important that you look at the
code i've written
but just know that if i gave you this
file and the data files
you could make the exact same figure
that i've made on the right
so here i can give my advisor the file
the data and they can make that figure
just as they want it i can define
all my files and data in just one place
and here with one line of code i can
easily change the coordinates that i'm
looking at
while keeping the rest of the figure
structure and aesthetics the same
so if my advisor wants to change the
region but have
everything else look the same i now only
have to do that with one line of code
bentobox also makes plots entirely
customizable just as you could for other
plots in r
i now have the power to really customize
a bunch of things about my plots
i can really easily change their color
palettes font sizes
font types dimensions etc etc
so let's say my advisor didn't like
those heat maps being red
and he wanted those bin signal tracks to
be slightly taller
we can now easily make both of our heat
maps with a blue color palette
and quickly adjust the dimensions of all
those tracks all while maintaining
picture clarity and not having to squish
any of our data
one of the really special customizations
in bento box
is its ability to perform coordinate
based plotting on a page
with precise placements and dimensions
so here we can define a bento box page
that is exactly nine inches wide and
five inches tall
and now we can make and arrange all of
our plots within this defined landscape
so if we want the top corner of a plot
to be do two inches down from the top of
the page and one inch from the left
and we want the plot to be three inches
wide and one inch tall
we can make exactly make our plot with
these parameters and it'll fit
right in that box we defined this exact
sizing and placement
is particularly important and useful for
standardized and accurate data
comparisons
so this both applies along the y-axis if
we're looking at two plots side by side
and they have the same scale we want to
make sure we're comparing that
data correctly and it's also important
for comparing data along the same
coordinates
of the x-axis so here in the case of
genomics we're looking at a specific
region along the genome
and we want to compare the data that's
specifically in that region
and while there are other tools like
patchwork and cow plot for arranging
plots in r
none are as precise and specifically
tailored for a multi-plot environment
like bentobox
so here i've made two example ggplots
using the empty cars dataset
and i'm going to show you how they work
differently in patchwork calplot and
bentobox
patchwork is specialized for the easy
arrangement of plots and grids
so here we can just define plot one plus
plot two and
patchwork will place them side by side
for us
and calplot expands on these grid
layouts and gives you slight more
control of the relative dimensions and
plot placements
so here i can define that i want the
left plot to be slightly smaller and
shifted to the left to the right
of the plot on the right but these
options both have issues of placement
and size accuracy which can become a
problem
both in terms of aesthetics and data
interpretation
so as you can see here the relative
placements and sizes of the plots mean
that they can easily get squished or
stretched especially when we're moving
around that our graphic device window
or if we're exporting it in different
sizes
this does not happen with bento box
plots because everything is aligned and
spaced
exactly how we want it to be so here if
we're placing those same plots
on a page that is defined to be eight
inches wide and four inches tall
we can see as we move the r graphic
device window around it adjusts to
maintain those dimensions
and despite plotting and customizing
extremely large data sets
bento box functions are extremely
efficient because they were optimized to
be able to quickly plot large data sets
so if we go back to our previous figure
that we made with bentobox
we can see how quick it is to generate
each of the main elements of our plot
so our two heat maps here took only 0.6
seconds to plot
our genomic labeling and our gene tracks
took .06 seconds to plot
each of our signal tracks took less than
a signal uh one second
to plot
and adding our gg plot took point four
seconds
in the end it only took my laptop about
three seconds to generate this whole
figure
coming from many large data files
and if our advisor wants us to visually
scan through our large
data sets we can now programmatically
and easily make them aesthetic
informative figures
in bulk so here i've made 20
files of the same style of figure
but looking through different regions of
a file
and they're all plotted in the exact way
i want them and i can easily scan
through all of this data
so now that we've gone through some of
bentobox's key features
i want to take you through a walkthrough
of a plot that we made with some genomic
data
so first we can initialize our bento box
page
with the exact dimensions in our unit of
choice
as an american i have chosen inches here
this function will by default add ticks
and guides to aid you in your figure
building process to make sure you're
placing things and arranging them in the
way
you want so first here we can add one
half of a heat map from a file and its
associated color scale at one corner
we can add the bottom half of this heat
map from a different file
in a different color palette with its
associated color scale
we can replace those two heat maps with
one square heat map that's exactly
three inches wide and three inches tall
and easily change its color palette
we can mark up the dark pixels on that
heat map that in the genomic field we
denote
as dna loops and we can do this with the
variety of options
so here we can do this with circles
or with arrows or with squares
and in this case we can just highlight
one specific loop region
and annotate that with text if that's
what we want to look at
we can next line up and add a different
representation
for these loop regions as two boxes
connected by
line segments and this tracks is exactly
the same width as our heat map and in
the height that we want it to be
or we can change this data into a
different representation
by marking them up as connected arches
below this and lined up to our heat map
and these arch representations
we can now add different bin signal
tracks from different files
and in different colors for each of
these we can change the y ranges
and the heights of all these different
plots
we can then line up the track of genes
that fall in this exact region of data
that we're looking at
so we can show both strands of the dna
show the structure of the genes and
label them
we can easily change the colors of every
element of this gene track
and make it all gray or all a different
color
or we can just highlight a specific gene
in a color of our choosing
and finally below this entire collection
of data we can label the x-axis of
genomic coordinates that we're looking
at
and really line it up to everything
we've built up so far
but beyond looking at these lined up
tracks of different data data that you
might
already see in a genomic browser we can
also add various plot elements to our
page in different locations
sizes and orientations really with no
limitations
so first on this right side we can now
add a picture representation of a
chromosome and a specified width
below that we can zoom in and highlight
a specific region of the chromosome
and add two different heat maps of the
same size and region right next to each
other to compare those two different
data types
we can change those square heat maps
into triangle ones
if that suits our fancy we can add two
more bin signal tracks below our other
heat map
heat maps this time making them the same
width as our smaller heat maps since
we're comparing along that axis
we can zoom in on a specific region of
that bin data to compare a specific peak
of data
and we can also add the sequencing read
pileups that represent that bin signal
data
and we can change the color for each of
the two strands of dna
finally again we can add our label
genomic coordinates below each of these
zoomed regions of data
and when we're done building up and
tweaking our plot to our liking
we can remove all of those guides from
our page and export our publication
quality figure
in the size we made it at the beginning
so we can use it in research papers
or presentations just like this one so
this entire plot
is exactly what i've built up in bento
box and so
if we compare bentobox to existing
programmatic libraries
we can see that both are programmatic
and reproducible
both are fully customizable and both
integrate
a wide variety of data types however
bentobox is specialized to handle large
data sets like genomic data
and only bentobox gives users the
precise control of plot placements and
dimensions
bentobox currently has functions for
genomic data
but i hope its paradigms will extend the
our plotting environment for all kinds
of data visualizations
if you're interested in trying out
bentobox and exploring how you can use
it with your data you can get ventobox
from my lab's github page or feel free
to tweet at me directly
thank you so much for your time
[Music]
you